I'm Jo and I work as an assistant practitioner in a CAMS service in Lancashire. I bought and read Marianne's book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to accompany me while completing the clinical psychology training application. It proved to be really good company. I found it sparked ideas of how to build experience and skills, but more than that, it offered the chance to get lost in people's stories. It provided a timely reminder not to get so caught up in an end goal and to value and enjoy each job we fulfill along the way because the work we do now is important and matters to those we sit
我是Jo，我在兰开夏郡的一家CAMS服务机构担任助理医师。我购买并阅读了玛丽安的书《临床心理学家集体》，以此陪伴我完成临床心理学培训的申请。事实证明，它确实是一个很好的伙伴。我发现它激发了我关于如何积累经验和技能的想法，但更重要的是，它让我有机会沉浸在人们的故事中。它及时提醒我，不要太执着于最终目标，而要珍惜并享受我们一路走来所从事的每一份工作，因为我们现在所做的工作很重要，对我们身边的人以及我们自己都意义重大。
alongside as well as ourselves. It also gave the reassurance that there are eclectic roots into clinical psychology, which is important for me as someone who's had a meandering journey and not a typical route to the profession. I wholeheartedly recommend the book for both personal and professional reasons. Be prepared to put evening tasks on hold for a while though because once you've started reading it's tough to put it down. When we think about supporting autistic individuals we might assume that all approaches are created equal, but that's not necessarily the case. Different models shape the way autism is understood,
它也让我确信，通往临床心理学的道路是多元的，这对于像我这样经历过曲折、并非走典型职业道路的人来说非常重要。我衷心推荐这本书，无论是出于个人还是职业原因。不过，请做好暂时搁置晚间任务的准备，因为一旦开始阅读，就很难放下了。当我们考虑支持自闭症患者时，我们可能会认为所有的方法都是平等的，但事实并非一定如此。不同的模型塑造了人们对自闭症的理解、诊断和支持方式，但它们对自闭症患者本身的影响并不相同。有些受到赞扬，有些存在争议，还有一些正在不断演变，以更好地满足自闭症患者的需求。今天，我们将深入探讨三个关键框架——PBS（积极行为支持）、TIC（创伤知情护理）和ABA（应用行为分析）。它们是什么，它们如何运作，以及专业人士需要了解什么。嗨，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安博士，很高兴能为您提供这些内容，我希望这些内容能真正帮助您在职业生涯中，有时也能在个人层面上，理解心理健康和服务提供中的一些关键问题。今天我再次邀请了汉娜，我们之前在播客中讨论过女孩的伪装和自闭症表现。
diagnosed and supported, but they don't all have the same impact on autistic people themselves. Some are praised, some are controversial, and others are evolving to better meet the needs of autistic individuals. Today we're diving into three key frameworks – PBS, TIC and ABA. What they are, how they work and what professionals need to know. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne and it is my pleasure to provide you this content which I hope really helps your professional but sometimes also your personal understanding of really key issues in mental health and service provision. Today I'm welcoming back Hannah who we previously had on the podcast discussing masking and autism presentation
很高兴她能回来，让我们更深入地思考这些模型。汉娜，很高兴你再次来到这里。欢迎回到《有抱负的心理学家》播客。非常感谢你的邀请，玛丽安。不用客气。所以，如果大家还没有观看或收听过我们之前的节目，我强烈建议大家去看看，因为这一期节目将是一个相对独立的篇章。上次我们讨论了女性自闭症的表现有何不同，以及伪装现象可能更为普遍，那是一期非常有用的节目，所以是的，谢谢你，希望大家能从中受益。今天我们正在思考一些模型。在深入探讨每个模型之前，你能否让我们了解一下，为什么在服务机构工作或对这一领域感兴趣的人，了解这些不同的框架和方法很重要？
in girls. It's really lovely to have her back to think more about these models. Hannah, lovely to have you back again. Welcome back to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Thank you so much for having me, Marianne. You are so welcome. So I would really recommend that if people haven't already watched or listened to it, that they check out our previous episode because this one's kind of going to be a little bit standalone where last time we spoke about how autistic presentation can differ in females and how masking might be around more and it's a really useful episode so yeah, thank you for that and I hope people do find that helpful. Today we are thinking about some models. Before we dive into each model could you give us a little bit of an understanding about why it's important that people kind of working in services or just with an interest in this
当然，当你与学习障碍或自闭症患者一起工作时，从他们的角度去思考问题非常重要，而要设身处地去理解那些有这些经历的人是非常非常困难的。因此，真正理解这些理论将帮助你做到这一点，并将更具同情心的关注点带入你的工作中。非常感谢。我完全同意。这真的非常非常重要。那么，考虑到PBS，也就是积极行为支持，你能给我们介绍一下吗？
area understand these different frameworks and approaches? Sure, so it's really important to think about things from the perspective of someone who has a learning disability or autism when you're working with these individuals and it can be very very difficult to put yourself in the shoes of somebody who has those experiences. So really understanding these theories is going to help you to do that and to bring the more compassionate focus into the work that you do. Thank you so much. I couldn't agree more. It's really, really important. So thinking
当然，没问题。积极行为支持侧重于主动策略，而不是被动策略。它着眼于系统性和整体性的干预措施，以帮助提高个人的生活质量。它秉持这样一种理念：如果你改善了个人的生活质量，那么对关注行为或挑战性行为的需求就会减少，因此这是一种处理这些行为的更系统的方法。它实际上是在2015年被NICE（英国国家卫生与临床优化研究所）采纳的，所以我相信它在NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）中得到了相当广泛的应用。哦，太好了，我知道过去使用的一些方法争议较大，所以如果它已被NHS采纳，我希望它的争议性会小一些。
about PBS, which stands for Positive Behavioural Support, could you tell us a little bit about that please? Sure, absolutely. So Positive Behavioural support has a focus on proactive strategies rather than reactive. So it looks at systemic and holistic interventions that will help increase an individual's quality of life. It has the kind of ethos that if you improve an individual's quality of life then the need for behaviours concern or behaviors that challenge will be decreased so it's a much more systemic way of dealing with those behaviors. It was actually adopted by NICE fairly recently in 2015 so it's used quite widely within the NHS I believe. Oh good and I know some of the
当然，我认为要记住的主要一点是，它仍然基于ABA的行为主义原则，但它正在转向主动而非被动的策略。因此，人们通常认为PBS更具人性化和同情心，因为它着眼于理解行为背后的意义，理解挑战性行为确实具有某种功能，并着眼于帮助满足那些未被满足的需求，而不是仅仅为了让某人的行为符合社会的期望而改变他们。
approaches used in the past have been a little bit more controversial so if this has been adopted by the NHS I'm hoping this is less controversial. Absolutely I think one of the main things to bear in mind is that it is still based on the behaviorist principles of ABA but it's moving towards that proactive rather than reactive strategies. So people often view PBS as much more humanizing and compassionate because it looks at understanding the meaning behind behaviors and understanding that behaviors that challenge do have a function and looking at kind of helping those unmet needs rather than just changing somebody's behaviours to kind of fit
所以它是在有争议的ABA基础上发展起来的，但仍然保留了一些行为主义原则。我认为近年来，人们已经转向“积极支持”而非“积极行为支持”，并持续剔除支撑它的行为主义方法。这非常有趣，但当你思考这种行为的功能是什么，以及我如何支持这个人以一种不会被视为具有挑战性的方式进行沟通时，它确实更加富有同情心，也更加以人为本。太棒了，所以它保留了有效的部分，并且，我想，精简并逐步淘汰了那些，嗯，让人们感到不太舒服的部分。
in line with what society would expect. So it's developed on from the kind of controversial ABA but it's still keeping some of those behaviourist principles. I think in recent years there's been a shift towards positive support rather than positive behaviour support and kind of that continued removal of the behaviourist approaches that underpin it. So it's very interesting but it's a lot more compassionate and person-centred as well when you think about what is the function of this behaviour and how do I support this individual to communicate that in a way that won't be seen as challenging. Great, so it's kind of keeping the bits that worked and kind of, I guess, streamlining and phasing out the bits that were, that yeah, kind of rubbed people not quite in the best
当然。我知道自闭症患者通常将ABA视为一种治疗自闭症的方法，这本身就是非常错误的，因为你无法“治疗”像自闭症或学习障碍这样的东西。这只是某人的存在方式以及他们看待世界的方式。当与非语言且无法进行口头交流的个人一起工作时，这些行为往往仅仅出于沟通某种需求的需要而产生。
ways. Absolutely. I know that people with autism often viewed ABA as a method to treat autism, which is in itself just very wrong because you can't treat something like autism or a learning disability. It's simply the way somebody is and the way that they view the world. And when working with individuals who are non-verbal and can't communicate verbally, these behaviors often arise just out of a need to communicate something.
我举个简单的例子。我曾与一位个人一起工作，他经常会靠你非常非常近，这种增加的亲密度被视为一种关注行为，但实际上那个人是在试图沟通他想要社交互动，而这正是每个人都应该能够获得的最基本的需求。这非常有同情心，你真的真的想把这些人视为人类，而不是你正在“处理”的对象，他们是可以与你一起合作支持的对象。因此，这种方法因为其更具同情心的视角，绝对得到了自闭症患者和学习障碍患者的更多支持。
I'll give a quick example. So an individual that I've worked with would often come very, very close to you and this increased proximity was viewed as behavior of concern, but it was actually that individual trying to communicate that they wanted social interaction and that's a very very basic need that everybody should be able to have access to. It's very compassionate, you really really want to view these individuals as
太棒了，谢谢。如果有人正在听这个节目，他们会想，好吧，如果我们正在使用PBS，而我们有一个人真的很喜欢站在这里跟我说话，我们该如何使用PBS来让这种互动对所有参与者来说都感觉更舒适呢？
humans rather than somebody that you're just working on, it's somebody that you can work with to support. So it's an approach that's definitely more supported by autistic individuals and individuals who have learning disabilities because of that more compassionate lens. Brilliant, thank you. If someone's listening to this and they're like, okay, so if we were using PBS and we've got someone who really likes to stand right here and talk to me, how would we be using PBS to kind of help that feel more comfortable for everyone involved in that interaction?
当然。通常使用PBS时，会制定一个PBS计划，这可能是在PBS诊所，也可能是在多学科团队会议中。这些计划通常有一个非常长的绿色部分，用于所有主动策略；然后是一个琥珀色部分，用于他们开始变得具有挑战性时；最后是红色部分，用于他们表现出挑战性或处于危机模式时。所以这是一个非常好的交通灯系统。因此，对于一个喜欢站得离别人很近的人，我们在绿色策略中可能实施的一件事，非常有帮助的可能是强化互动。
Absolutely. So what usually happens with PBS is that a PBS plan will be developed and this might be at a PBS clinic or it might be within an MDT meeting and these plans kind of have a very long green section which is for all the proactive strategies and then an amber section which is as they're starting to become challenging and then red when they're being challenging or in crisis mode. So it's a very nice kind of traffic light system. So one of the things that we might implement in the green strategies for an individual who likes to stand very close to others, something that might be very helpful could be intensive
即为他们提供机会，以一种对他们来说更合适的方式进行互动和建立社交联系。如果他们的这种需求得到了满足，那么这可能有助于减少在其他更不合适的背景下出现这种行为。太棒了，非常感谢你为我们阐明了这一点，汉娜。我认为这个播客我最喜欢的一点是，我也能学到一些我不太自信或不熟悉的东西，所以很高兴能开阔眼界，了解心理学领域中我目前没有涉及的其他事情。这让我想起我在住院服务机构工作时，我们使用了一家名为RAID的培训公司的方法，它是在思考，嗯，那个“绿色”部分，但它可能不是我们可能正在寻找的那种绿色。所以我猜这听起来很相似，它关乎思考如何通过明确的指导来获得最佳结果，从而为所有参与其中的人从每一次互动中获得最佳效果。是的，绝对，我完全同意这一点。
interaction. So giving them opportunities to have that interaction and have that social connection in a way that's more appropriate for them. And if they have that need met met then that might help to diminish the behaviour arising in other more unsuitable contexts. Great thank you so much for illuminating us on that Hannah. I think one of my favourite things about this podcast is that I get to learn stuff that I am not that confident or familiar with as well so it's really nice to have my eyes open to other
如果有人正在观看这个节目，因为他们可能有一位正在接受治疗和护理的家庭成员，考虑到这在NICE指南中，这是人们可以要求为他们所爱的人进行探索的事情吗？当然。他们绝对可以要求制定并实施PBS计划，我认为这是考虑支持个人的最佳方式，因为它非常关注我们能做什么来预防，而不是我们将做什么来应对。所以我非常鼓励人们、家庭成员要求制定这些计划，这绝对是他们可以要求的事情。
stuff that's going on in areas of psychology that I don't currently work in. It was making me think about when I worked in inpatient services and we used an approach by a training company called RAID and it was kind of thinking about, well, that baby is green but it's maybe not quite the shade of green that we might be looking for. so I guess it sounds kind of similar to that it's about thinking about getting optimal results with clear instructions about how to how to get the optimal best out of every interaction for everyone that's involved in it. Yeah absolutely I would definitely agree with that.
太棒了。我知道有些人对表现得直接或自信会感到有些犹豫。但在我为NHS服务机构工作时，实际上，就你感到好奇或可能听说过的事情进行双向对话是可以的。这不像走进那里说，“我要求CBT，或者我必须有这个，或者我必须有那个。”这更像是，“你熟悉那个吗？那是你能够在服务机构中实施的框架吗？”
If someone's watching this because they perhaps have a family member that's receiving treatment and care, given that this is in the NICE guidance, is this something that people are able to ask to have explored with their loved one? Absolutely. They can definitely request that a PBS plan is created and put in place and I think that is the best way to think about supporting individuals because it's very much focusing on what can we do to prevent rather than what are we going to do to respond to. So I would very much encourage people, family members to request that these plans are made
当然，我认为只要与你合作的专业人士开启对话，并说“你知道，我听说过这种方法，这可能是我们可以探索的事情”，也许专业人士有其他想法，或者了解其他可能更合适或不太合适的方法，能够进行这种对话真是太好了。我认为从系统性的角度来看，当家庭成员更多地参与并愿意进行这些对话时，协调护理并与个人保持一致要容易得多。所以根据我的经验，绝对鼓励与家庭成员进行对话。所以永远不要觉得这是你不能谈论的事情，或者不是你该谈论的事情，因为这绝对是我会鼓励的事情。
and that's definitely something that they can ask for. Brilliant. And I know some people can feel a bit hesitant about being directive or assertive. But when I've worked in NHS services, actually it's OK to have a two-way conversation about things that you wonder about or might have heard about. It's not like going in there and saying, I demand CBT,
太棒了，非常感谢。创伤是我的专长，而“创伤知情”这个词，嗯，这些天它们到处都在出现，不是吗？甚至连自称为“创伤知情”的教练可能只是参加过一次培训课程或读过一本关于它的书，然后就可以合法地称自己为“创伤知情”。但你能告诉我们为什么对自闭症患者进行创伤知情护理如此重要吗，汉娜？
or I must have this, or I must have that. It's like, are you familiar with that is that a framework that you are able to to kind of to implement in in this service? Absolutely and I think just opening up the conversation with the professionals that you're working with and in saying you know I've heard about this approach with this might be something that we could explore and maybe the professionals have other ideas or have knowledge of other approaches that might be more appropriate or less appropriate and it's great to just have that conversation and I think looking at things from that systemic point of view when family members are more involved and willing to have
我认为当你与自闭症或学习障碍患者一起工作时，创伤知情确实着眼于理解创伤在这些群体中的普遍性。生活在一个并非为你设计的世界中，本身就会产生很多创伤，还有诸如机构化、忽视、欺凌、歧视等事情。创伤的来源有很多，这确实有助于我们理解为什么它如此普遍。但在与这些人一起工作并思考“我如何才能做到创伤知情”时，这实际上只是采取理解那个人及其个人经历的方法，思考“你发生了什么”，而不是“你有什么问题”，并试图防止再创伤，因为不幸的是，这也是非常普遍的事情。
these conversations it's much easier to coordinate care and to stay consistent with individuals as well. So I think from my experience, conversations with family members are definitely encouraged. So don't ever feel like it's something that you can't speak about or something that's not really for you to speak on, because it's definitely something that I would encourage. Great, thank you so much for that. So trauma is my specialism and the terms trauma informed, well they crop up absolutely everywhere these days don't they? Even coaches calling themselves trauma informed might just have been on one training course or read a book about it and then could legally call themselves trauma-informed. But can you
当然，只是想到我自己可能在住院服务机构工作的经历，或者与有相当多额外需求、智力障碍或学习障碍的人一起工作。你可能会看到什么？什么样的行为？所以我想到的是，一个受过创伤的人可能不一定会表现出一些，你知道，我们可能习惯看到的症状。这些可能更大或更小。我们可能会在人们身上看到什么样的迹象表明他们经历过创伤？
tell us about why trauma-informed care for autistic individuals is so important, Hannah? I think when you're working with individuals with autism or a learning disability, being trauma-informed really looks at understanding the prevalence of trauma within these communities. Existing in a world that wasn't designed for you creates a lot of trauma in itself and there's things like institutionalization, neglect, bullying, discrimination. There's so many different avenues for trauma and that really helps us to understand why it is so prevalent. But when working with these individuals and thinking how can I be trauma informed, it's really just taking the approach
当然。我认为最大的一点是对系统的不信任。所以你并不觉得专业人士能够以你需要的方式支持你，因为也许你以前被辜负过，或者你有过不愉快的经历。但这可能是非常小的事情，比如环境，东西太亮或太吵，或者如果事情没有以一种可访问的方式向你解释，那也可能非常可怕，它可能会导致他们想到以前的经历。
of understanding that individual, their personal experiences, thinking what's happened to you rather than what's wrong with you, and trying to prevent re-traumatization because that is something that is unfortunately very common as well. Absolutely and just thinking about my own experiences of working perhaps in inpatient services or people with quite a lot of additional
我认为在与经历过创伤的人一起工作时，最好的方法就是非常“神经肯定”（neuroaffirmative），允许人们成为真实的自己，并问他们，“你知道，这个环境可以吗？你想让我关上门还是留着它？”我认为，在他们所在的地方与他们会面是最好的方法。是的，而且我认为，你知道，即使我们被送进综合医院，不仅没有那种控制权，而且一切都太吵了。你知道，我生两个孩子时就在那里。所有的垃圾桶都非常吵。所有的门似乎都非常吵。你知道，如果我有一些额外的需求，或者我在那里待了很长一段时间，我会很快变得非常烦躁。你知道，这实际上是在思考，当人们被送进医院时，这就是他们的家，实际上我们需要真正思考如何帮助他们在那种环境中茁壮成长。
needs with intellectual disabilities or learning disabilities. What might you be seeing? What kind of behaviors? So I'm thinking about someone who is traumatized might not necessarily exhibit some of the, you know, just some of the symptoms we might be used to seeing. These could be much bigger or much smaller. What kind of things might we be seeing in people that might indicate that they've experienced trauma? Absolutely. I think the biggest one is a mistrust in the system. So you don't feel as though professionals can support you in the way that you need,
当然，我认为我们能做的就是尽量为他们创造一个安全和可预测的环境，并理解对你我来说完全没问题的事情，实际上可能对他们产生巨大的影响。是的，只是试着带着同理心和同情心去思考，我们如何以我们能做到的最好方式帮助这个人。而且我猜我们谈论的很多人可能是非语言的或选择性缄默的。所以这真的是在思考如何真正理解他们身上可能发生的事情，如何，我猜在合乎道德的地方，反馈给了解这个人的家人、朋友、护理人员。
because maybe you've been let down before, or you've had experiences that wasn't pleasant. But it can be very small things, such as the environment, things are too bright or too loud, or if things aren't explained to you in an accessible way as well, that can be very scary and it might then lend them to think about previous experiences.
当然，如果一个人有沟通护照或医院护照，其中会概述他们如何沟通，他们的需求是什么，甚至可能是过去的经历，那些没有帮助的事情。阅读这些文件并在见到他们之前让自己了解这些人的需求，我认为是非常有帮助的。如果你正在与一个没有沟通或医院护照的人一起工作，并且你认为这会有所帮助，那绝对是你要求的事情。我认为患有学习障碍或自闭症的人，我认为他们真的都应该有一个，因为它真的非常有帮助，而且它还可以概述他们需要的任何合理调整。所以创造那种他们需要的环境和空间。这些文件真的真的可以对此有所帮助。
I think the best approach to take when working with someone who has been through trauma is to just be very neuroaffirmative, to allow people to be their authentic selves and to ask them, you know, is this environment okay? Would you like me to close the door or leave it open? And meeting them where they are is the best approach, I think. Yeah, and I think, you know, even if we're admitted to physical health hospital, not
太棒了。我想你一定看到我在你还没问之前就取消静音了，因为你说你要回答这个问题。所以我本来想说，人们怎么得到其中一个，汉娜？所以非常感谢你为我们的听众阐明了这一点。当然。服务机构是否在广泛推广并为自闭症患者提供创伤知情护理方法，还是说这目前仍然有点小众？
having that control, but also how loud everything is. You know I was in there when I had both of my babies. All of the bins are incredibly loud. All of the doors seem to be incredibly loud. You know if I'd had some additional needs or I've been there for a protracted period of time, I would have got really old really quick. You know and it's thinking about actually when people are admitted to hospital, this is their home and actually we need to be really thinking about how to help them to thrive in that environment. Absolutely, I think what we can do is just try to create a safe and predictable environment for them as much as possible and understanding that
所以根据我在学习障碍领域工作的经验，我并肩接受了积极行为支持和创伤知情护理的培训，我认为这是最好的方法。我只能谈论我目前工作的服务机构，所以我不知道在其他服务机构工作的人的经历。但是的，根据我的经验，我们正在接受培训，这真的真的很有帮助。但我认为，是的，它总是可以扩展的。告知人们关于创伤和积极支持的信息，并确保每个人在与这些人一起工作时都有那种非常具体的理解，这没有任何坏处。当然，你知道，无论我们与谁一起工作，我认为谈论创伤的影响永远不会是浪费时间。
something that's completely fine for you or I might actually be having a huge predictable environment for them as much as possible and understanding that something that's completely fine for you or I might actually be having a huge impact on them. Yeah, just trying to think with that empathy and compassion about how do we help this individual in the best way that we can. And I guess a lot of the people we're talking about might be non-verbal or selectively mute. And so it's really thinking about how to really understand what might be going on for them, how to, I guess where it's ethical, feed into family, friends, caregivers who know this person well as well.
当然。那么，如果我们看看我们同样的案例研究，那个走过来跟我们说话的人。如果是在创伤知情服务中，我们该如何处理或干预呢？当然，你会想要了解他们过去的经历，如果我们理解其功能是他们想要社交互动，那么我们可以看看，好吧，为什么那是一个未被满足的需求？他们过去经历了什么，导致他们无法获得那种互动？然后利用这一点来帮助制定关于如何最好地照顾他们的想法。
Absolutely and if an individual has a communication passport or a hospital passport which will outline how they communicate, what their needs are, maybe even past experiences that things that wouldn't be helpful. Reading through those documents and making yourself aware of these individuals needs before you see them is something that I think is really helpful. And if you're working with an individual who doesn't have a communication or hospital passport and you think it would be helpful, that's something that you can definitely request. I think individuals with learning disabilities or autism, I think they should all really
所以我们可以思考，如果这是一个可能被机构化的人，并且可能没有机会以他们需要的方式真正与人互动，那么我们可以思考如何将这种互动融入他们的日常生活中。所以如果他们生活在护理环境中，我们如何鼓励照顾这个人的人更多地与他们互动？我非常喜欢的一种技术是主动支持。所以这是在观察每一个时刻似乎都有互动的潜力。所以这可以是如果你正在为这个人做家务，比如洗涤或沐浴，这个人可能能力较弱的事情，但我们仍然可以鼓励他们参与其中并进行互动。所以如果他们真的很难理解如何洗自己的衣服，你可以在做这件事时与他们交谈，他们可以和你站在一起看着你，你可以说，“现在我把洗涤剂放进机器里，你想帮我倒粉吗？”你知道，非常非常简单的事情，但允许他们在日常生活中以及在支持他们的环境中拥有这些非常小的互动机会，并从创伤知情的角度理解，也许这是他们并不总是有机会做的事情。所以让他们的员工真正了解关于那个人的这一点，并理解为什么我们与他们一起做这些即使是非常小的事情也如此重要，因为正是这些小事产生了最大的影响。
have one because it is just so helpful and it can also outline any reasonable adjustments that they need. So creating that kind of environment and that space that they need. These documents can really, really help with that. Amazing. I think you must have seen me unmute myself when you were like, I'm going to answer the question before she asks it. So I was going to say, how do people get one of those Hannah? So thank you so much for illuminating our audience so well on theirs. Absolutely. Are services kind of widely rolling out and delivering a trauma-informed care approach for people with autism or is that something that's still a little bit niche at the moment?
当然，而且我一直在想一个人缺乏控制权，特别是在他们可能真的很喜欢的人周围，你知道。人们无法控制某人是否会辞职并离开服务机构，而且我一直在通过创伤知情的视角思考这一点，也许有人走过来站在这里实际上真的很喜欢你。而在过去，你知道，他们不知道他们最喜欢的员工成员何时会进出病房或他们的家，几乎不想有这种惊喜，因为无法处理那种知道他们不在那里的惊喜。所以实际上如果我让你留在这里，我就能跟着你，知道你什么时候要离开。所以
So my experience of working in LD, I've had training in positive behaviour support and trauma-informed care side by side and I think that's the best approach to take. I can only speak about the service that I'm working in at the moment, so I don't know the experiences of people working in other services. But yeah, from my experience, we're receiving the training and it's really, really helpful. But I think, yeah, it can always be expanded. There's no harm in informing people about trauma and positive support and making sure everyone has that really concrete understanding when working with these individuals. Absolutely, you know, whoever we're working with I think no bad time is spent talking about the impact of trauma.
我猜这只是理解某人站在那里的动机来自哪里。他们过去受过伤害，这真的很有用。当然，我曾与显然经历过这种情况的人一起工作。不幸的是，这非常普遍，但我使用过的一种方法是“现在和以后”板。所以当员工轮班交接时，我们可以有一个小板子，上面有现在谁在工作、以后谁在工作的图片，甚至像视觉时间表，这样个人就可以看到谁每天都会在那里，好吧，我最喜欢的员工今天不在，但我明天会见到他们，拥有这些视觉工具来真正帮助个人
Absolutely. So if we're looking at our same case study then, the person that's coming right up here to speak to us. How might we be dealing with that or intervening if this was in trauma-informed service? Sure, so you would want to understand what their past experiences were if we understand the function to be that they want social interaction and then we can look at okay why is that an unmet need? What have they been through in the past that hasn't allowed them to have that? And then using that to help formulate ideas
理解，好吧，他们没有离开，他们只是结束了轮班，这可能是一件非常非常难以沟通的事情，当员工确实离开时，这也可能非常有挑战性，特别是如果他们经历过很多次这种情况。我发现社交故事可以提供帮助，简单的阅读材料可以将其置于更直观的格式中，但这确实是你必须与那个人一起努力的事情，因为失去那个你真正依赖于这些非常基本的日常技能的人，而他们不再在那里，这是一种非常真实的损失。所以我认为保持创伤知情并理解这确实有非常真实的影响，以及我们如何为那种感觉留出空间，
in how best to care for them. So we can think about if this is an individual who has maybe been institutionalized and maybe hasn't had that opportunity to really interact with people in the way that they need, then we can think about how do we integrate that interaction into their day-to-day lives. So if they're living in a care setting, how do we encourage the people that are caring for this individual to interact with them more? And one technique I really like is active support. So this is looking at every moment kind of has potential for interaction. So this can be if you're doing like domestic chores for this individual, so maybe washing or bathing, something that this individual might
我们如何允许他们感受它并验证它，而不是仅仅试图继续前进并可能改变它。当然，非常重要的考虑因素，而且我知道过去ABA一直更具争议性，这就是我们谈论的那种有争议的，而且我认为肯定在美国，它可能得到了很多负面报道。据你所知，它在英国还在使用吗？如果是这样，它如何以一种富有同情心和有效的方式使用？据我所知，ABA主要用于慈善部门，在NHS中使用得并不多。
have less capacity to do, but we can still encourage them to engage in it and to have that interaction. So if they really struggle to understand how to wash their own clothes, you can talk to them whilst you're doing it and they can stand with you and watch you and you can say, now I'm putting the washing in the machine, do you want to help me pour in the powder? You know very very simple things but allowing them to have these very small opportunities for interaction within their day-to-day lives and within the setting that's there to support them and understanding that from a trauma-informed perspective that maybe this is something that they've not always had the opportunity to do. So allowing their staff to really understand that about the individual and understand why it's so important that we do even these very small things with them, because it is the small things that make the biggest impact.
它更多是在游戏的背景下实施的。所以使用提示来发展社交技能和沟通。它使用的更具争议性的技术之一是像正强化和惩罚，以帮助发展这些技能。我认为人们已经更多地转向远离那种方式，但是的，它仍然存在于可能具有那种非常近距离接触的人的背景下。
Absolutely, and I guess I was thinking about someone's lack of control, especially around people that they might really like, you know. People can't control whether someone's going to resign and leave a service, and I guess I was thinking about that through a trauma-informed lens, that maybe someone coming and standing right here actually really likes you. And in the past, you know, they don't know when their favorite member of staff might be coming or going from a ward or their home and almost don't want the surprise because can't deal with the surprise of knowing that they're not there. So actually if I keep you right here I'm going to be able to follow you and know when you are going to be leaving. And so
如果你在游戏的背景下使用它，正如它经常被使用那样，你可能会做的一件事是，你可能会停止与他们玩，并建立起，好吧，他们需要理解他们不能靠得这么近，然后当他们退后时，你再与他们重新接触并继续与他们玩。或者你可能会使用提示，你可能会说“太近了”或“退后”或类似的话，来提示他们意识到，好吧，太近了，我需要退后。所以它在那种时刻对于像那样的事情是有帮助的，当个人有能力理解
it's I guess just understanding where the motivation comes from for someone to stand there. They've been hurt in the past, can be really useful. Absolutely and I've worked with individuals who have obviously experienced this. It is unfortunately very common, but something that I've used is a now and then board. So when staff are transitioning from shifts, we can have like a little board with pictures of who's working now, who's working later, or even like a visual schedule so individuals can see who's going to be there each day and okay my favorite staff isn't here today but I will see them tomorrow and having those visual tools to really help the individual
这意味着什么时，但与患有自闭症或学习障碍的人一起工作，有时他们可能缺乏那种洞察力，即使是提示或脱离接触，根据我的经验，它可能并不那么有效，因为他们确实倾向于缺乏那种洞察力，而且在与这些人一起工作时，界限总是困难的事情。所以这可能具有挑战性，这不是我最喜欢使用的技术，但有些人确实非常喜欢它，当它以适当的方式使用时，它可以是有效的。是的，它让我想起了一种我们过去在住院部使用的方法，叫做“toots”，即“当场暂停”，是的，我认为
understand that okay they're not leaving they're just finishing their shift and that can be something that's very very difficult to communicate and when staff do leave that can be also very challenging, especially if they've experienced that a lot. I find social stories can help and easy reads to put it in a more visual format, but it is something that you're going to have to work through with that individual because it is a very real loss to not have that person that you really relied on for these very basic everyday skills that they're no longer going to be there for. So I think being trauma informed and understanding that that does have a very real impact and how can we hold space
其中一些感觉有点像把一个成年人当成孩子一样对待，你知道，你可能会对你的蹒跚学步的孩子做的一些事情，而且我认为，也许那方面的某些东西就是那些并不总是让人感觉那么人道或仅仅是那么合乎道德的东西。当然，我认为它通常被视为试图治疗自闭症，这显然不是我们可以做的事情。自闭症是一种看待世界的方式，是一种存在方式，所以它不是我们可以治疗的东西，拥有那种视角，支撑理论的所有那些想法并不太好。但没有ABA，我们就不会有积极支持，所以它导致了
for that, how can we allow them to feel it and validate it as well rather than just trying to move on and maybe alter it. Absolutely, really important considerations and I know in the past ABA has been more controversial that's the kind of controversial one we're talking about and I think certainly in the States it might have got quite a lot of negative press. Is it still used to your knowledge in the UK and And if so, how can it be used in a way that is compassionate and effective? So to my knowledge, ABA is mostly used in the charitable sector and it's not so much used within the NHS.
护理方面的一些非常重要的发展。所以我们必须承认好的一面和坏的一面，我想。是的，确实如此，谢谢。如果有人想更多地了解这些方法，是否有像一本好书或一个好资源，或者只是读一下NICE指南，哪里是一个很好的起点，汉娜？当然，我的意思是，网上有所有的指南，你可以浏览并搜索不同的技术。YouTube上有很多视频和类似的东西，以一种非常简单和直观的方式解释它，这对于患有学习障碍或自闭症的人来说可能是有帮助的。
It's kind of implemented more in the context of play. So using prompting to develop social skills and communication. One of the more controversial techniques that he uses is like positive reinforcement and punishment to also help the development of those skills. I think there's been more of a shift away from that, but yeah, it's still around in the context of somebody who maybe has that very close proximity.
但也有很多研究论文，你可以阅读，谈论如何实施它以及它是如何发展的，理解其中的一些历史，我认为也非常令人兴奋。对我来说，无论如何，不是对每个人，但是的，有很多不同的地方你可以查看，仅仅搜索PBS ABA，就会出现很多不同的资源。谢谢汉娜，老实说，你太棒了。我不认为你意识到你有多棒。而且今天我也像个噩梦一样，因为我时间紧迫，而且它，你知道，我知道播客看起来总是非常无缝。今天一点也不无缝
One thing that you might do if you're using it in the context of play as it is often used is that you might then stop playing with them and kind of establish that okay they need to understand that they can't be this close and then when they move back then you re-engage with them and continue to play with them. Or you might use prompting, you might say too close or move back or something along those lines to prompt them to realise okay too close I need to move back. So it can be helpful in the moment for things like that to when individuals have capacity to understand
而你只是顺其自然。所以我很高兴我有机会之前见到你，这样你就知道情况并不总是那样，但你，你知道你的东西，我很兴奋看到你的职业生涯带你去哪里。哦，那太客气了。非常感谢。在我们结束之前，
what that means but working with individuals with autism or learning disability sometimes they might lack that insight and even the prompting or the disengagement, it might not be as effective in my experience anyway because they do tend to lack that insight and boundaries is always a difficult thing when working with these individuals anyway. So it can be challenging and it's not my favorite technique to use but some people do really like it and when it's used in the appropriate way then it can be effective. Yeah it reminded me of an approach that we used to use an inpatient called toots which was timeout on the spot and yeah I think
你还有什么想留给我们的听众的最终观点吗？当然，所以PBS，如果你从这个视频中带走一件事，那就是PBS是关于生活质量而不是行为，并且拥有创伤知情PBS框架对于以合乎道德和有效的方式工作是如此重要，这样我们就可以将我们的关注点从挑战性行为转移到未被满足的需求的沟通上。而且我认为这个使神经多样性个体人性化的过程将有助于消除一些那种污名，并以一种更具同情心、基于证据、创伤知情的视角工作，而且那是
some of it felt a little bit potentially like infantilizing someone that's a grown adult you know some of the stuff that you bit potentially like infantilizing someone that's a grown adult, you know, some of the stuff that you might do with your toddler and it's, I think maybe some of that aspect is the stuff that hasn't always felt that humane or just that ethical. Absolutely, I think it's often viewed as trying to treat autism which is obviously not something that we can do. Autism is a way of viewing the world, it's a way of being, so it's not something we can treat and having that lens, all those kind of thoughts underpinning the theory isn't too great. But without ABA we wouldn't have positive support, so it has led to
我们真正将如何改善人们的生活质量。是的，确实如此。再次感谢你抽出时间阐明这次对话，在那些我认为没有得到太多通风和没有得到太多播出时间的领域。所以我希望人们发现这真的真的很有用。非常感谢你，也谢谢所有收听的人。我对此非常有热情。所以我真的真的鼓励人们参与那些引发关于神经多样性和学习障碍对话的内容，因为你谈论得越多，我们就越能消除污名。你的热情从你身上闪耀出来，所以继续做你正在做的事情，我相信辉煌的事情会发生。
some very important developments in care. so we have to acknowledge the good with the bad I think. Yes indeed we do thank you. If anyone wanted to learn more about these approaches is there like a great book or a great resource or would it just like have a read of the nice guidance where's a great place to start Hannah? Sure so I mean there's all the guidance online that you can look through and searching up the different techniques. There's lots of videos on YouTube and things like that that explain it in a very easy and visual way that might be helpful for an individual who has a learning disability or autism.
哦，非常感谢，也谢谢你的邀请。老实说，非常感谢汉娜。你知道，我和很多嘉宾交谈过，汉娜真的非常了解她的东西。令人钦佩，真的很令人钦佩。我确实希望你觉得这有帮助。如果你正在YouTube上观看，请务必在评论中给汉娜或我或我们俩留言。请务必让我们知道你为什么在观看，关于你的一点点信息。如果你的评论与其他人产生共鸣，请务必回复他们。请考虑订阅他们的
But there's lots of research papers as well that you can read through that talk about how to implement it and how it was developed and understanding some of that history I think is really exciting as well. For me anyway, not for everyone but yeah, there's lots of different places that you can look and just simply searching up PBS AVA there's lots of different resources that come up. Thank you Hannah and honestly you you're so good. I don't think you realize how good you are. And today I've been a bit of a nightmare as well because I'm pressed for time and it like, you know, I know the podcast always look really seamless. Today has not been seamless at all
频道，这样我们就可以真正帮助在YouTube上建立一个支持性的社区。如果你正在Spotify上作为MP3收听，你可以给节目评分。如果你正在Apple Podcast上收听，你可以给节目评分和评论。无论你在哪里收听播客，你能为任何播客做的最友善的事情就是关注他们的节目。它不会花费你一分钱，但它确实非常有帮助。如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，现在是你的时间，你已经准备好迈出下一步，请务必查看我的书《有抱负的心理学家集体》、《临床心理学家集体》，而《有抱负的心理学家会员资格》是一个非常好的地方，我们拥有大量的
and you've just rolled with it. So I'm glad I got a chance to meet you before so that you know it's not always like that, but you are, you know your stuff and I'm excited to see where your career takes you. Oh, that's so kind. Thank you so much. Just before we finish is
专家真正帮助你提升你的技能，你在关键领域的信心，如CBT，在反思中，在像CAT、系统性等方法中，各种各样的事情。面试技巧、准备、练习、谈论自己的信心以及迎接挑战。你可以以每月仅30英镑的价格加入，没有最低期限。如果你是自闭症患者，或者你正在试图帮助为自闭症患者辩护或激励自闭症患者，请务必查看我的另一本书《自闭症选集》，这是自闭症患者或被认定为可能患有自闭症诊断的人的真实生活神经叙事记录，以及他们在心理健康服务机构工作的经历。这是一本美丽、鼓舞人心的读物。如果你读过那本书，我们将欢迎
there any kind of final points you want to leave our audience with? Absolutely so PBS if you take away one thing from this video it would be that PBS is about quality of life rather than behavior and that it's so important to have the trauma informed PBS framework in order to work in an ethical and effective way so that we can shift our focus from challenging behaviours to communication for unmet need. And I think this process of humanising neurodivergent individuals will help to remove some of that stigma and work with a more compassionate, evidence-based, trauma-informed perspective that's, and that's
您还有什么最后的观点想留给我们的听众吗？当然，如果大家从这段视频中只能学到一件事，那就是PBS（积极行为支持）关注的是生活质量而非行为本身。拥有创伤知情的PBS框架对于以合乎道德且有效的方式开展工作至关重要，这样我们才能将关注点从挑战性行为转移到未被满足的沟通需求上。我认为，这种将神经多样性个体人性化的过程，将有助于消除部分污名，并以一种更具同理心、基于证据且创伤知情的视角开展工作，而这正是
really how we're going to improve people's quality of life. Yes, indeed. And thank you again for your time in illuminating this conversation in areas that I don't think get much ventilation and don't get much airtime. So I hope that people find this really, really useful. Thank you so much and thank you to everyone who listened. I am very passionate about this. So I really, really encourage people to engage with content that sparks conversation about neurodiversity and learning disabilities because the more you talk about it, the more we can remove the stigma. Your passion shines out of you, so keep doing what you're doing and brilliant things will happen, I am sure.
真正改善人们生活质量的方法。确实如此。再次感谢您抽出时间来阐明这些我认为很少被讨论、很少有曝光度的领域。我希望大家能觉得这非常有价值。非常感谢您，也感谢每一位收听的听众。我对这个话题充满热情，所以我真心鼓励大家去接触那些能引发关于神经多样性和学习障碍讨论的内容，因为讨论得越多，我们就越能消除污名。您的热情溢于言表，请继续坚持下去，我相信一定会取得卓越的成果。
Oh, thank you so much, and thank you for having me. Honestly, thank you so much to Hannah. You know, I speak with a lot of guests and Hannah really knows her stuff. Admirable, really admirable. I do hope you find this helpful. If you're watching on YouTube, please do drop a message in the comments to Hannah or to me or to both of us. Please do let us know why you're watching, a little bit about you. And if your comments resonate with other people, please do reply to them. Do consider subscribing to their
哦，太感谢了，也谢谢您邀请我。说实话，非常感谢Hannah。你知道，我采访过很多嘉宾，Hannah确实非常专业。令人钦佩，真的很令人钦佩。我真心希望大家觉得这期节目有帮助。如果您是在YouTube上观看，请务必在评论区给Hannah或我，或者我们俩留言。请告诉我们您为什么观看，以及关于您的一些情况。如果您的评论引起了其他人的共鸣，请务必回复他们。也请考虑订阅他们的
channels as well so we can really help build a supportive community on YouTube. If you are listening as an MP3 on Spotify, you can rate the show. If you're listening on Apple podcast, you can rate and review the show. And wherever you're listening as a podcast, the kindest thing you can do for any podcaster is to follow their show. It doesn't cost you a penny but it really is helpful. If you are an aspiring psychologist and it's your time and you're ready for the next step please do check out my books The Aspiring Psychologist Collective, The Clinical Psychologist Collective and The Aspiring Psychologist Membership is a really great place where we have a whole host
频道，这样我们就能真正帮助在YouTube上建立一个支持性的社区。如果您是在Spotify上收听MP3，您可以为节目评分。如果您是在Apple Podcast上收听，您可以为节目评分和评论。无论您在哪里收听播客，对任何播客创作者来说，您能做的最友善的事就是关注他们的节目。这不需要您花一分钱，但真的非常有帮助。如果您是一位有抱负的心理学家，并且觉得时机已到，准备好迈出下一步，请务必查看我的书籍《有抱负的心理学家集体》、《临床心理学家集体》，而“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”是一个非常棒的地方，我们有大量的
of experts really helping you to up level your skills, your confidence in key areas like CBT, in reflection, in approaches like CAT, systemic, all sorts of things. Interview skills, preparation, practice, confidence in speaking about yourself and rising to the challenge. You can join that for just £30 a month with no minimum term. If you are autistic or you are trying to help advocate for somebody who's autistic or inspire someone who is autistic, please do check out another of my books, An Autistic Anthology, which is real life neuro narrative accounts of people who are autistic or identify as having likely an autism diagnosis and their experiences of working in mental health services. It is a beautiful, inspiring read. If you have read that, we would welcome
专家真正帮助您提升技能和自信，涵盖CBT、反思、CAT、系统性方法等各个关键领域。包括面试技巧、准备、练习、谈论自己的自信以及迎接挑战。您只需每月支付30英镑即可加入，且没有最低期限要求。如果您是自闭症患者，或者您正在努力为自闭症患者倡导权益，或激励自闭症患者，请务必查看我的另一本书《自闭症选集》，其中收录了自闭症患者或认为自己可能患有自闭症的人的真实神经叙事，以及他们在心理健康服务领域工作的经历。这是一本优美且鼓舞人心的读物。如果您读过这本书，我们欢迎
your reviews. Psychologist baskets Without a Marian treat Hello, my name is Veronica Kasova. I live in Edinburgh and I just graduated with a Masters in Psychology of Mental Health. Marian recommended me the Clinical Psychologist Collective when I was not working on LinkedIn and I must say I love it. It is one of a kind. It's like a window into the lives of people on the path of becoming a psychologist. The stories are unique, honest, and filled with a kind of intangible wisdom only personal storytelling can uncover.
您的评论。心理学家篮子，没有玛丽安的款待。你好，我叫维罗妮卡·卡索娃。我住在爱丁堡，刚获得了心理健康心理学硕士学位。当我没有在领英上工作时，玛丽安向我推荐了临床心理学家集体，我必须说我非常喜欢它。它是独一无二的。它就像一扇窗户，让我们得以窥见那些走在成为心理学家道路上的人们的生活。这些故事独特、诚实，充满了只有个人叙述才能揭示的那种无形的智慧。
A common thread in the stories I valued most was to be compassionate not only with others but with myself too. Also not fixating on becoming a psychologist but enjoying life, growth and the final results will come as a by-product. Marianne thank you for taking the time to collate all the stories, the book is a true gem and I think every aspiring psychologist should have a copy on their shelf. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我在最珍视的故事中发现的一个共同点是，不仅要对他人的富有同情心，也要对自己富有同情心。此外，不要执着于成为一名心理学家，而是要享受生活和成长，最终的结果将作为副产品自然到来。玛丽安，感谢您花时间整理所有的故事，这本书是一颗真正的宝石，我认为每一位有抱负的心理学家都应该在书架上放一本。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。